Hey Thoughty2 here.
A 2015 study ranked The United Kingdom as
the world leader in “soft power” – that’s
the ability to influence other nations by
“whispering in their ear”.
The United States on the other hand is the
world leader in “hard power”, using their
vast military might to beat other countries
into submission.
Put it this way, if the UK is Peter Baelish
then America is The Mountain.
The difference in approaches between the two
nation’s foreign policies has a lot to do
with the way each country’s government functions.
The British government has what’s called
a “division of power”, in which the Prime
Minister is not the country leader but is
simply the head of government as well as an
advisor to Her Majesty the Queen, whom is
the true head of state.
The President of the United States however,
is the one and only head of state and executive
leader over the entire country and its people.
All this basically means that in the US, a
hell of a lot of power is given to one person.
Apart from perhaps Putin, there are few heads
of state the have more individual power than
the US president.
Even Kim Jong-Un has to share his power with
his deceased grandfather, who is technically
still President.
But in reality, how real is the American President’s
power.
How much power do they really possess?
Will Donald Trump be able to build a wall
without permission from Congress?
Should you be scared?
The President of the United States or POTUS
is effectively a dictator.
As long as he or she sticks within the confines
of the law, the POTUS is free to do whatever
they please.
However, if this power was pushed to its limits,
the POTUS would face impeachment, they would
have their presidency swiftly removed.
So for this reason, and to gain the approval
of the general public, in the hopes of winning
a second term in four year’s time, presidents
often behave and do what the majority of the
American public wants them to do.
But if a President weren’t sound of mind
and had no morals what could they theoretically
do?
Well to start with an obvious one, the President
is “Commander in Chief” of the military
and can do whatever they please with it 1.5
million troops and endless toys.
And that’s not just the troops at home,
the President has total control of 800 military
bases in 70 countries across the globe.
Oh, and let’s not forget the 7,000 nuclear
warheads at the President’s disposal.
What about a bit closer to home?
What damage can the President do to their
own peoples.
Since they are in charge of powerful organisations
such as the CIA, NSA and FBI, the President
can find out whatever they like about pretty
much anyone and enforce any punishments they
so desire, in a heartbeat.
The president also receives intelligence from
numerous allied countries.
Lawmaking is a different kettle of fish and
is often where most presidents come unstuck
on their path to power.
If the president wishes to amend or create
laws they have to create a bill which is passed
through congress.
If it receives a majority vote in congress
the bill is passed to the president to sign,
if he signs, it’s then the law.
Simple, right?
Well, that’s only if congress is on the
President’s side.
That’s to say the President’s political
party has more seats in congress than the
opposition party.
Obviously, if you have more friends on your
side, then congress is more likely to vote
in favour of any bills you pass.
And it just so happens that when Donald Trump
is inaugurated, he will have a majority number
of Republican Seats, in both chambers of Congress:
The House of Representatives and the Senate.
In fact, the current Congress is the largest
Republican majority since the 1930s.
Even if Trump’s majority congress doesn’t
vote in his favour of his fatuous plans, for
some reason, he can always turn to an Executive
Order, which is basically there so the President
can turn his middle finger up at Congress
and do what he likes anyway.
Congress can always pass legislation that
opposes the President’s executive order,
but the President is free to veto anything
that Congress passes, so yeah, I think he
would probably do that.
If a President’s executive order is in conflict
with the constitution it can be taken to the
Supreme court, who have the power to either
allow it or quash it.
Which historically would have acted as a nice
balance to stop the President’s power getting
out of control – this next term however,
because some supreme justices are retiring
soon, and other reasons, Donald Trump will
have the rare opportunity to pick who he would
like to be part of the Supreme Court, giving
him considerable leverage over the most powerful
court in the land.
He may get to replace four of the nine justices.
And when you consider that the average serving
time of a Supreme Court Justice is 26 years,
who he picks now will affect the country for
generations.
Anyone who achieves the title of President
of the United States is inevitably going to
become one of the most powerful individuals
in the world.
Franklin D. Roosevelt is often thought of
as the most powerful president in history.
He certainly issued the most executive orders,
by a mile.
But with ever increasing usage of executive
orders and a Republican majority at his back,
some experts theorise that Donald Trump will
have more power at his fingertips than any
predecessor.
I’m sorry if you aren’t satisfied with
this answer, if so, you may want to look at
emigrating to any of these five countries,
which statistically have the most stable political
systems in the world.
I’d personally go for Denmark, they have
unbelievable breakfast pastries, but that’s
just me.
Thanks for watching.